- The reason there's gonna be
a billion motivational views
today on YouTube is that people
love the feeling of being
motivated, they don't like
putting in the work to do
something about the feeling.
(turn signal ticking)
(somber electronic music)
- [Gary] Morning!
(airplane engine whines)
Thank you so much.
- [Pilot] See ya later.
- Thank you, see you soon.
We're not in
New York City anymore.
Losers are losers
for a reason, DRock.
- [DRock] Why do you say that?
- People allow emotions
to get the best of them.
(light piano music)
No room for emotion
in the big leagues.
Passion, yes.
But being clouded
by insecurities
is a huge vulnerability.
Think that there's, there's
a lot of different things we
could talk about, first
I wanna get clarity, Neil,
when you say engagement, we
wanna grow engagement across
all platforms, are you actually
referring to engagement
metrics or are you referring
to top line follow count?
So the answer to your question
Neil, and Jess and team,
is there's a lot of different
things you could do.
I think at the end of the day,
did I lose them (chuckles)
Hey guys, sorry about that,
I'm back, I'm up in
Lake Placid, I'm actually about
to give a keynote speech
in the stadium where the
U.S. stunned the Soviet
Union in 1980, I'm excited.
That had the biggest
audiences in the world,
and them really sitting back
and understanding what our
relationships are with them,
how we're structured,
and then coming up with
the big creative campaign
to drive follow count, I think
could be a massive win.
Yeah, what's goin' on with that?
It doesn't get
firm until the, yeah,
but the fluctuation
on that is very small.
No, I mean, let me
give you an example,
the likelihood of currency
going up 30% in that period
is .001%, and think about
what that actually means,
you know, it would mean
something if you were buying
bordeaux at 80 bucks, but
if you're buying something
at six bucks and
it goes to $7.80,
the stuff we're buying right
now, it's not gonna matter.
(hip hop music)
Hi, how are you?
- How are you, I'm Laura.
- Laura, such a pleasure.
- Nice to meet you.
- How are things?
- [Laura] Things are good,
how 'bout you?
- Good.
(hip hop music)
This is so cool, this is
such a legendary stadium.
- [Gary] I made it.
- [Libby] How are you?
- [Gary] Good, how are you?
- [Libby] Good, I'm Libby.
Nice to meet you.
- Chuck, how are you?
Such a pleasure.
- Gary, Dave Morrison,
nice to meet you.
Thanks for being here.
- Thanks for having me.
What, for you guys,
would be most exciting
for me to focus on?
You know, is it the
motivational part?
Is it the tactical part, like?
I do feel that people
that are attracted
to your business model
rely way too much on you.
The person that's willing
to sign up for your thing,
or a business that is
franchisees or things
of that nature,
whether it's McDonald's
or it's the guy who
started something yesterday
and he's got three franchisees,
the DNA of the person that
signs up for a franchisee,
like, I would never do that.
My intuition is you
would never do that.
So it's an interesting thing.
There's a part of them
that's 90% entrepreneur,
and 10% like, "What's the
mothership gonna do for me?"
And I'm always trying
to focus them on like,
"Forget what the
mothership's gonna do.
"You're in full control."
If you spend a minute on
what the mothership does,
that's a minute away from
what you could be controlling.
You signed up for
this for a reason.
Thank you, brother.
What's your name?
- [Justin] Justin.
- Justin, nice to meet you.
Want me to sign it real quick?
- Yeah, could you make
it to a friend of mine?
- [Gary] Yeah.
- [Justin] Chris Green
is his name.
- [Gary] Chris?
- [Dave] He's gotta go
on in like one second.
Thanks, Gary.
- [Justin] Thank you,
I appreciate it.
- [Gary] Take care.
Nice to meet you man.
- A lot of people excited
to see you, my friend.
- [Gary] Yeah, I'm excited.
Digital is human, it's
just scalable human.
- [Dave] That's right,
that's exactly right.
- You know what I mean, I mean.
People are always like,
"Yeah, but do you have a
real connection with somebody
"that you talk to on Twitter?"
I'm like, "Tell me
what the difference is
"between that and writing
a letter 80 years ago."
Like, yes, I do.
Yeah.
- [JT] So 12 weeks ago,
I started JT in the Raw,
weekly Facebook live show,
and I'm getting now
five to 700 views on Facebook,
then repurpose it
load it up on the--
- Youtube.
- Youtube with subtitles,
blog it, send it out.
I picked up two
clients here in the US
because of that.
- 100% man.
And it works.
Listen, I know my stuff works.
I just know that
99% of the people
aren't gonna do
anything with it.
- Yeah.
- I can tell you what to do.
A screwdriver works, but
if you don't go and do it,
then that
screwdriver sucks shit.
I don't think
people understand.
First of all, I've
been talkin' about this
since I wrote Crush It! in 2009.
This is nothing new.
This is just momentum.
Like, that phone?
That's the remote
control of our lives.
Like, this has just started.
Like, this isn't, this is here,
but this is just the beginning.
Like this only becomes
exponentially far more extreme.
(applause)
- [Announcer] I also have one
more bit of exciting news.
I could not be more excited
to introduce our next speaker.
Entrepreneur, social media
legend, wine connoisseur,
digital media guru, venture
capitalist, best-selling author,
lover of the hustle and
CEO of VaynerMedia,
you guys probably
know him as GaryVee.
Please help me welcome
Gary Vaynerchuk.
(applause)
- Since the beginning of time,
literally all the way back
to the printing press,
before we've had
this seismic of a shift,
have you not understood
what's happened in our society
around the notion of
communication?
Have we not understood
that 10 years ago,
if you were online dating,
you were the weirdest
fuckin' nerd of all time,
and now 80% of this audience
is swiping right 24/7/365.
(audience laughs)
- What the fuck is
'a matter with you?
You can get anything
answered in the world
on a site called
Google in two seconds.
If you can't read like
me, you can watch a video.
If you love reading, knock
your fuckin' socks off.
But, the reality is how
do I do ads on Instagram
takes three minutes.
You're just not
putting in the effort
because you're
trying to do tactics.
You haven't made the religious
decision that you understand
that the world is
fundamentally changing forever.
My friends,
it's not coming back.
We're not gonna all sit around
and watch fucking MASH.
It's over.
- [Woman] Well played.
- You got into the speech.
- [Woman] Okay,
but I'm proud 'a ya.
I don't have (inaudible) either.
(laughing)
That was a lot of fun.
Thank you.
Thank you, thanks for having me.
- You just have to
go up a set of stairs.
- How's it goin'?
- Good, man, how are you?
- Thank you, brother.
- Good job, man.
You're my third
Twitter follower now.
- Thanks, man!
What's that, yeah.
- That was a great talk.
- Awesome.
Stay well.
- [Woman] I think you're
getting picked up out here.
- Great stuff.
- Thank you so
much for havin' me.
- Great speech, man.
- Thank you, brother.
- I listen to your podcast
on a weekly basis--
- Thank you.
- And, I'd be a fool if I didn't
take the time to
shake your hand.
- Thank you so much.
- And, what's your name?
- I'm Corey.
- Corey, where ya from?
- Indiana.
- Very nice, man.
- Yep.
- You havin' a good
conference so far?
- Yeah, it's great,
it's great, thank you.
- You're welcome.
Take care, man.
Talk to you soon, take care.
We were talkin about private
label champagne, I was like,
hey, maybe we
should do something
like Cliquot owns orange.
We should own a color.
Oh, wait a minute, maybe we
should own like light blue,
and go the Tiffany's style
because it speaks to elegance
and that justifies
a $40 champagne.
I'm do this for DRock,
but you're just gonna
be the recipient on it.
We've been talking
a lot lately about
like the speed in
which I execute.
I think it comes
down to the reason
I'm able to do so much
shit is 'cause I know
that almost
everything except for
the five biggest macro issues,
if you do a 91 or an 86 or a 79
out of a 100 on that issue,
it's pretty much the
same as net score,
and it's not more
valuable than the time
that you dictate to it.
That's always
what I tell you about
like the main
wine offering, right?
It's like, "Fuck, it
wouldn't have mattered."
And, then you end up spending
an hour and a half debating,
and really there was
gonna be no difference
one way or the other.
And, if it was, it was
gonna be so marginal
compared to the
value of your time.
Anyway, sorry.
That's your first
appearance on a rant.
(laughing)
Good job, Brandon.
Look at the matrix right now.
What have you not created?
Thank you, my friend.
Thank you so much.
What have you not created,
or what is glaring oh
for five in the matrix?
- [Man] Give me a
second for a photo?
- Yeah, of course, let's do it.
- Let's do it.
- There ya go.
- Glad we snuck this in.
- Thanks for everything.
- Thanks again for having me.
- Good shit, we loved it.
- Take care of yourself.
- Yeah, I'm getting
really great feedback.
Thank you, take care.
Yeah, for sure.
How ya doin?
Josh.
How are you, man?
- Good.
- Kabeira.
- Kabeira, real pleasure.
How are you?
Just got it in.
- A few months ago,
I started followin' you,
like I started
seein' like online,
and all that on Facebook,
and I was like man,
I got hooked right away.
- Thank you, man.
- Like he was sayin',
your fuckin' energy
is just outta this world.
And then, today,
I was goin' through like,
well, yesterday, we were
goin' through like the--
- Who's gonna be on?
- And, I was like,
"No fuckin' way!"
"I've been followin' him!"
"He's the shit!"
- Let's do it.
(laughing)
I love it, thank you.
Let's get in here.
- Sweet.
- All right, guys.
- Thanks, man.
- Wish you well.
- Yeah, absolutely.
- Take care of yourself.
- Good luck to you man.
- Absolutely.
- Stay well.
- Take care, man.
Thanks for the love.
We're gonna have to,
once we layer what
justifies how many we need,
you know what I mean?
Once we get that logic, how
many cases a year we sell,
how many cases
do we have in stock,
and the computer tells
you how many you need,
it's over.
When it really,
mathematically understands
that you need
three $20 pinots, you know?
At the end of the day,
I'm a retailer.
I'm, you know,
the quick action of B to C,
versus the long game of B to B.
Is such a difference
between Wine Library
and VaynerMedia.
I get such a high
from the transactions.
It's kinda where like
speaking is instant feedback,
you know?
eBay, selling, instant feedback.
Vayner's much
more long lead time.
Two, three months,
land a client.
Fascinating differences.
Both fun and fruitful, but
like very different games.
All right, can we just do the
single most important thing
real quick?
(laughing)
I want to start a podcast, and,
ah, man, all right,
actually, you know what?
I think we're
gonna start a podcast,
and we're gonna produce
it at VaynerMedia,
and you and one of
the wine staff members
are gonna come, I'm being
dead serious, by the way,
and I love that idea called
What Are We Drinking?
Where seven people
taste the same wine,
don't know what
the other people thought,
and we just record
the tasting notes,
and that's the show.
I just think that's funny.
Yeah, I'm gonna do it.
All right, you gotta go?
All right, see ya, bye.
Thank you so much my friend.
Take care.
- [Pilot] Hi, welcome back.
- [Gary] Thank you.
No, listen, Tyler.
Like, you know,
the reason I said that,
is there's a reason that
guys and gals like me
continue to have audiences,
because people
want to be motivated
to go and do things,
or they want to learn
tactics to go and do things,
but whether I'm giving
you tactical advice,
like filters on Snapchat,
or Facebook ads,
or Instagram story
collaborations,
or I'm motivating
you through my word,
because I communicate that way,
or through my actions,
seeing this wake up at five,
if everybody who's watching this
actually did something about it,
and then went on the course
of their version of it,
then they wouldn't
be watching this,
and I genuinely know at
the bottom of my heart,
out of all the people that
want to build audiences
that I'm the complete opposite
of almost all of them.
(electronic beat)
99% of people
that produce content
like this that are
out there like I am,
the business of being
that is what they are.
I have businesses.
I have Wine Library
and VayerMedia.
I don't need your
14 bucks for my book,
or to be in my course,
or this and that,
so I don't need to
monetize you, so I,
then genuinely want you
to never watch me again.
The problem is, every
time you guys are posting,
do you know how many times
I see on my Instagram,
oh, I needed this today,
and you know how many
times I see that person
nine months later
still hanging around?
Okay, there we go.
There we go.
Finally. Finally.
If you needed it,
then take it and
do something about it.
The reason there's gonna be
a billion motivational views
today on Youtube is that
people love the feeling
of being motivated.
They don't like
putting in the work
to do something
about the feeling.
I hate the motivational me,
until you do something about it.
(light music)